this is a production of Cornell
University
okay what is that great honor to be here
today and thank you for joining me and I
hope you enjoy my I talk and so today we
talked about suppression of the awesome
you system and how instead the microbe
in fact arose take control now I would
like to give you a brief introduction
about an immune system and you can see
here different pathogens and they're
trying to attack the plant cells and
possibly to gather nutrients on the
other part we have our plant cells that
during the coevolution develop strategy
to first recognize these pathogens and
then to perfectly give a defense
responses and these rely on the plant
immune system and we can divide these
plant immune system two major layers one
is called a PT I am trigger immunity and
it relies on a surface receptor kinase
called PR R pattern recognition receptor
this receptor can perceive concern
molecule from pathogens these are called
pumps pathogen associate molecular
patterns now when this receptor like
ethyl is to recognize flagellum will
first associate with a co-receptor
for example back 1 and which is a is
required for the signaling and this will
follow a calcium elevation followed by a
rose production rose are reactive oxygen
species like hydrogen peroxide and the
antigen peroxide will oxidize all the
membrane and cause cell death so the
pathogen cannot spread and for many of
the pathogens is the end of their
journey but also bacteria koval with the
plants and then they develop different
strategies like effector molecules this
molecule are translocated directly
inside the cell and they can manipulate
interfere
with the PTI so we don't have anymore
the Ross production and here we have the
second layer of plan immune system
called ETI and we have another class of
receptor also known as resistant
proteins thinking specifically recognize
effector molecule and trigger the ETI
effective effector to immunity which is
a faster stronger response now you can
see these are different kind of audience
and you have a bacterium nematodes
fungus and it's also nice to see that we
have this effort system fitting these
models and this is a new entry this is a
recent concept of f it secretin
effectors to moduli to modulate the
plant Aust
so what are these effectors so effectors
are molecule produced by pathogen that
modify or small area behavior to enable
porosity and we have different kind of
effectors for example apple plastic
effectors these are secreted to the O's
extracellular space and they can target
those proteases
we have also cytoplasmic effectors and
these effectors trans okay the inside
cell and can suppress or otherwise many
plate loss processes now
characterization of molecule functions
or effectors provide key information for
understanding processes underlying plant
colonization by pathogens and this is
but what I'm doing with my research I'm
trying to functionally characterize a
factor from different part of system now
let's go back and this is my little bit
of my background so I tell my bachelor
master degree in plant biology in Turin
and in Italy and after that I did my
study in in England in Norwich and here
is try to expand my research topic and I
was studying plant inside interaction
and more recently I
here in the US at USDA race and my study
was were focusing on a plant inks at
microbe interaction and now at UF I'm
also trying to develop tools in order to
solve a recurrent problem and I'm also
interested in interaction between fungus
in an inset so after my studying touring
I went in Norwich and here they have a
really nice research park and for
example this is a genomic analysis
Center we have the central laboratory
and the John Innes Centre and I was able
to establish a collaboration between a
university of turin and the jimenez
center and here i was we were trying to
functionally characterize effector
protein from 12 it - Percy and diesel
and here is a TM picture from an episode
and you can see it is a peculiar mouth
part now for a plant pathogen to be
successful manipulation of how cell
processes to promote violence is a sting
shot which is achieved by the secretion
of molecule terminal factors and to do
that we use this a novel approach based
on a combination of bioinformatics and
functional si si to identify factors
from my dispersion and these are how we
identify these effectors so we start
with the es T's seller grant from my
dispersion then we look for protein
contain a signal peptide signal peptide
tends to the cell to translate outside
the protein and then we remove all the
protein with the transmembrane domain so
we want a protein attack a move and we
finish to identify 46 candidate
effectors so this one of the functional
analysis we need to characterize these
effectors and so we overspreads this
candidate in Nicosia Romanian
and then we cut leaf discs and use it as
acrylic plate and then we add the four
means each leaf disc and then we count
the number of names produced and one
effect or NPC or to increase the number
of the names when they were feeding on
this plant so he may in indicated these
products in important on the plantings
and interaction we also have two and p10
mp40 two that actually decrees the
numbers of name produced and we also
found that MP 10 he's actually using
claw rosa and a week sell that but also
he can suppress PTI and used by pamphlet
jelly and is a quiet contradiction of
observation right so the hypothesis is
them always pressure on an MP 10 is
actually triggering some plant defense
responses and perhaps in a normal
athlete plan interaction other effector
are suppressing these response and MP 10
cannot contribute to the barians by
suppressing the PTI now there is another
way to functionally characterize gene
function and is using an RNA silencing
so we can knock down the gene expression
of genes so all these are interference
works so if we know the sequence of our
name is danger we can a synthesize
double seller name and then deliver to
their cells which will recognize this
double star on a using dice enzyme we
will chop the double array in small
interference RNA and then with complex
with risk which will identify the
corresponding messenger RNA and block
the prescription now at that time there
were two system for double sonoran
delivery was a the injection or
artificial diet but both system have
some drawbacks for example you need an
injector you need to make glass needles
you need to produce double
and also for the artificial lights you
need to optimize the dial for the
efforts need to replace the diet because
contamination and bothered are in
artificial condition so I decide to use
a different system and I use this vector
that's allowed this pressure on double
surname implants so I generate
transgenic Arabidopsis expressing double
sorry to target a few genes and I also
use a transient expression using a
nicotine nicotine amine tamiana and I
want to show you the results using a
transient expression so we select two
genes one mp0 from saliva gland is the
gene that increased the night names when
the EF it fitted unknown of expression
plant in a gut protein we want to see if
the signal was able to move from the gut
and as a salaried LAN and this is the
results who's in the leaf disk I showed
you before and he's after 17 days of f/8
feeding on this plant expressing double
sorry you can see we can suppress the
gene expression of both genes and these
are almost 50% which is similar to the
amount of silence and you can get with
double with the injection and with the
feeding on artificial diet these are a
feed feeding on a double strand RNA and
this is the fecundity results we found
that silencing NPC ought to reduce the
number on in produce so if you're over
spreads this gene increase the number of
death names if you sinus this gene you
decrease the number of the names
produced and this Iraq is the gut
protein so we think that it may be
important for up taking natural so by
silencing then we have a less natural
uptake and that will decrease the
fecundity so these are northern blot
using the leaf tissue and we are
expressing double our array in plants
but we can detect a small interfering
RNA so this is the Leafs tissue from
plant expressing double sonora 4mp co2
and this frog rock so as I told you
before the fan recognized doubles RNA
and chopped in small interfering RNA so
the F it is actually up taking more
interference RNA and this was a quite
system that I developed to have a easy
way to deliver double sonare and I
didn't expect the Ben later this system
was actually used not only an aphid on
but another he said species but also it
can be used as a tool for infant
management now we were also interested
in see if these Fe defectors have adapt
to modulate processes in a specific
plant species so we have a generalist
effort like - perception and we have a
specialist evidence like a piece we can
fit on your leg you so we generate
transgenic plant expressing my
dispersion factors in transgenic plant
expressing a pidgin orthologs
and anyway the deaf equality essay on
honourable OPS's and so these are we
work so we add the adults on the plant
then we wait for new name so we can
synchronize the age of the names and
then we catch them again and then we
wait for 16 days and we count the number
of the names produced and these are is
the results so my dispersion effect or
promote fertility images per second only
when they are feeding on plant
expressing my suspense which affect us
not when they are feeding on a pigeon or
tall herbs and we reveal that there is a
high nonsynonymous versus anonymous
nucleotide substitution rates with the
effector dogs so indicating the
defectors in my dispersion are fast
evolving as a consequence of
evolutionary
sure which dries rapid is
diversification on a vector function to
improve function when they are secreted
in the cell or for escaping the
recognition my plan immune system and
this is the last work we did with
efforts and at the beginning I show you
that one day earliest physiological
response to pump is a calcium elevation
and we found that if it feed inside
triggered these calcium elevation is a
transgenic plant expressed a biomarker
that binds calcium and is the site of
the figure they feed inside of every now
we didn't see calcium elevation when we
use a transgenic plant expressing this
biomarker in the phloem so only when the
F it was the problem in the mesophyll
and we found that this castle in
elevation is a bad one dependent back
one is the chorus scepter required for
signaling this is a is a back one mutant
we don't have anymore the calcium
elevation and also there is a bachelor I
on China tpc one that contribute to the
to the calcium elevation and this is a
mutant for the tpc one and we have a
lower calcium concentration but if we
use a TP c 1 overreaction with a burst
of calcium that can actually we use a
fake unity say on this plan and reduce
the aphid performance so if it trigger
calcium elevation during probing of
epidermal Amazo fuel cell and saliva
which contain effectors RC is secreted
into the cell types different cell types
and it can actually suppress the feeding
site of calcium elevation in most cells
along the stylet pathway are unsure
entry celery and we know that the cellar
puncture by using the letter electrical
penetration graph and you can see here
there is a Hafidh wired and now this is
a part of the circuit
so when
efforts are probing with a stylet we
generate a signal which is converted in
a waveforms and this way for
corresponding corresponds to a
particular feeding behavior for example
PD is a potential drop when then they
stylet function the cell you wanna eat
you is a is when they this stylet reach
the phloem and start feeding so you can
see benefit ensure many epidermis amazed
filled cell so this is the model now if
it similar to plant pathogens inject
protein into host plants to manipulate
all cell process enabling successful
infestation of plant and here is a cell
with stylet and syllabic antenna factors
you can modulate the PGI response okay I
don't know so concluding remarks so in
our world provides important evidence
that herbivores inks it similar to plant
pathogenic microbes secrete defector
inside host cells the internet most
protein a modified their activity to
facilitate infestation so this was my
work during my PhD and after that I
moved to here in u.s. in Florida and
first with the USDA error s and our UF
I'm trying to conduct research to
develop and transfer solution to solve
agree agriculture problem and so how do
we transfer basic principle to disease
management programs how can we come
for vector using sustainable system how
can we reduce the economic impact caused
by plant disease
how do minimize the input and maximize
output and so I want to show you a
screening I developed to identify
citrus-like susceptible to conquer
disease this is a canker disease and as
a is a caused by these bacteria Santa
monitors and these are the symptoms on
leaves and on fruits now we know that
during the pti
plant cells using the PR r receptor like
a Phyllis - can recognize flagellum and
start the PDI but we can also use a
peptide called a flex flagellum 22 so we
don't need to use the living bacteria
use a peptide and this will trigger the
same pti response with the Ross
production so because that I designed
these screaming and I show you how it
works so like we can we take leave this
from citrus plants and then we use this
96 place we put the leaf disc on this 96
place plus the flattening these are the
list of the trigger hydrogen peroxide
and we can compare this addition
peroxide in a signal and this is the end
result and you can see that really quick
is quick response after a few minutes we
can measure the hydrogen peroxide and
then we have a peak and then he goes to
basic level but what's interesting is
that we have different level of Ross
production and I found that citrus more
susceptible to citrus canker produce low
amount of Ross why plant less
susceptible to c2 skunker produce high
concentration of rose and so I screener
hundreds of citrus this is a cattle
ranchers roses is a sour orange and then
a separate planned with high rose
production implant with the lower rows
production
and then I in fact this plan we live in
bacteria and a high Ross production
corresponding to lower conclusion and
with love Ross production correspond to
high
anchor illusion II so with this system
live pathogen is substitute with the
flagellum peptide particular when the
pathogen is regulated and is a rapid
method for identified sitter sitting
less to settle to Santa Monica tree and
you don't need to propagate plans for
pathogenicity test and now this system
is implemented in situ hybrid selection
I USDA for peers now this system allows
you to identify plan that are less
susceptible but we have some cities they
are normally very susceptible so it
don't they don't produce high browse so
how can we improve the tolerance the
resistant of this plant so in this case
we use the transgenic stools so we took
the floods effortless to PRRS scepter
from an e-coat elementary jana and we
generate transgenic sweet orange with
orange usually produce with lower rows
using a flagellum 22 and these are the
results so transgenic plant is pressing
Nikitina been tamiana efflux to as a
high ross compared to the contour and
these again after infection with living
bacteria caused less lesion on the
leaves so of expression of Nicotiana
phyllis to in transgenic citrus
increased conquer resistance now i will
switch to another citrus disease and
this is call citizen graham beam it
shall be or citrus greening disease this
is the one of the most destructive
disease of citrus worldwide and is
already jeopardizing all the far Florida
citrus industry and probably it is
pretty really quickly and if you have
these nice grow
in Florida without proper management in
less than five years you can add end up
like this you can grow skeletons in
right now in Florida we have more than
130,000 acres of groves abandoned so
these are diseases caused by
candidatos libera back Thursday Atticus
and is a spread by therefore in a c3
which can fit all cities these are
typical symptoms of HIV you have a
uneven distribution of yellow and to
give you some numbers know if it is
interfering okay so Cilla's was
initially detect in Florida in 2005 and
since then the production of boxes
dropped from 300 million to 68 millions
at the same times the cost of of the
acres increased from 700 dollars to more
than 2000 dollars in a most important
there is no cure for HIV disease and
there are many groups that are trying to
figure out how to fight back this is a
bacteria and the way we are trying to to
fight this bacteria as some nice novelty
so we are trying with this multi to
multi institutional collaboration to
develop a synthetic bacteria with this
particular feature feature so we want a
culture bacteria
see last right now is no culturable and
these are slow down the research on this
photosystem
and we wanted to create also as a
correction system to deploy bacterial
scene so we can use this bacteria which
is culturable which has assistant to
secure it by piercing and so we can use
as a cross protection against heelas but
also this system not only can work in
sylla's you can potentially be used for
studying other Patou system and so we
have a different team task and for
example SGI under by craig Venter and
2010 it was the for the first time was
able to generate a synthetic bacteria
from scratch in laboratory so they are
taking care of a synthetic genome
generation and here in Crennel Michele
is working on a vector acquisition and
transmission and at USDA in Fort Pierce
they are working and looking for
bacteria in there can be used against
Sheila's and these are my tasks so I'm
trying to identify a factor gene there
are helping the synthetic bacteria to L
the infection also I'm looking for gene
that can may induce pathogenic so we
want to in we want to include genes that
allow infestation now we want to remove
gene that can cause autogenic and I'm
also looking for a mechanical creature
inoculation system so they will be give
us a quick way to study the bacteria
without using the vector right now and
this is the name of this synthetic
bacteria and we called libera back there
defense forum and awfully we can use it
to fight Sheila's so first ask effective
identification so I'll see las
manipulates is lost and so to do that so
Sheila's is a from limited bacterium and
they take advantage of his vector Siletz
a similar to f80 it used the stylet to
probably plant cells and eventually then
find the SIP elements here an infected
city will secrete also the bacteria and
this bacteria will secrete effector
proteins
now this effector proteins can move the
phloem and possibly target different
organelles and modulate plant function
so this is the pipeline we used to
identify sylla's effectors and it is
similar to the one we use for a
veterinarian efforts so we start with
the Assad steel as coding genes and wine
and then we apply different filters like
presence of signal peptide and we've
removed protein without with the
transmembrane domain so we end up with
28 putatively secret effectors and then
we clone without the signal peptide so
we asked over suppress all in the mature
protein in Nicosia Elementary Jana and
we also look for localization of this
effector implant and we look also for
phenotypes and one of this protein last
5315 it was really interesting as you
can see it two days later this pressure
he had cell that and I will talk about
this in the next few slides and but also
these a protein was targeting a
chloroplast we can see the protease
signal surrounding the the chloroplast
and also this protein was inducing
Carlos the pollution in the vascular
tissue and this is one of the symptoms
we have in HIV disease band we have a
high colors deposition the vascular
tissue and this is the de protein you
can see there is a signal peptide but we
also have a chloroplast targeting
sequence and then the rest of the
protein so the last 5315 is a protein
without the signal peptide and then i
generate another construct without a
signal peptide in a chloroplast
targeting sequence
and while the 5315 was causing cell
death the one without the chloroplast
targeted sequence was causing chlorosis
and I found that the chlorosis was a
caused by starch accumulation so this
protein trigger a massive starch
accumulation in leaf and you can see
during the day we have a cumulation the
starch and the more interestingly we see
that during the night there is no
degradation the starch and we also look
from some gene expression of gene
related to the starch synthesis and
starts degradation and this gene related
to the starch degradation or
downregulated
and it shall be symptoms are caused by
mass massive starch accommodation until
chlorophyll structures are disrupted
with the resulting qiraji so this
protein seems to be very important in
the HIV photosystem and there is also
some follow up of this protein since we
discovered these effectors candidate
other groups are working on these
effectors and they found first that is a
protein is highly secreted in plant
infected and can be used as a detection
marker as this protein is moving away
from the bacteria so we can detect these
infection even if the bacteria is not
present in the leaf by another part of
the plant and also they found that these
proteins play a key role in the HIV
pathogenicity now i was talking about
cell death causing by disease factors
and we found three factors causes cell
that an effector to community relies on
a resistant protein that recognizes
effectors in a specific manner in you
see program cell that to prevent the
pathogen from spreading and one of the
component for this response are they are
resistant protein so the idea is that
nikhat elementary Jana as resistant
protein they can recognize this effector
while Cetus doesn't have it
so we are now in collaboration with the
Michelle we want to try to see if we can
identify this our gene from Nakata
Elementary Jana
so we over spread these defectors in
Makati elementary Jana fuse to reflect
that and then we can bind with magnetic
beads this tag and possibly our gene
interacting with the protein and then we
remove washing all the other ausrotten
and then we can synthetic an sequence
the our gene and if we have an R gene
from nickel Jana been tamiana they
recognize this effector we can
eventually generate a transgenic citrus
expressing an e-coat element beyond our
gene they can allow the sea to spawn to
recognize alas and be immune to it now
for this photo system the best
management for this disease is the
prevention of this in the introduction
an establishment and so it's important
to have a system for early detection so
you can remove the infected plant and
avoid spreading on in your groves and
these are really fascinating a way to
detect seedless infected citrus tree and
in usda-ars King got well in this group
they are using dogs to
recognized Sheila's infected three and
it is talking detect the infection two
weeks after inoculation usually with
Cooper she takes two to 12 months not
because the cou PCR is no reliable but
because the sampling of the tree is
difficult if you think the sillies can
feed on the top of the tree and then you
take leaves random list you can have a
negative tissue so these are a really
nice way to detect
sylla's in the Groves now these dogs
recognize plant early volatize triggered
by Sheila's bacterium right now we know
the Cilla's bacterial secretes effector
molecules after injection after
infection and we can detect is a gene
vector gene after six hour after
inoculation and is a factor we know that
they can travel through the vascular
system and modulate us activity some
idea was are these dog detecting
volatize triggered by effector molecules
so and so I designed this experiment we
have four buckets contains 16 Nicotiana
main tamiana plants and wild type net
control in 16 selasa spectrum these are
the effector that our earliest press
during infection and the dogs when they
identify a Cilla's infected citrus they
sit down they never work with the with
the nicotine remain tamiana and i am the
only one that knows the dis bucket
contained se las effectors and so we run
the dogs we use the eight dogs and he's
a dogs first bucket second bucket and
this is a bucket with the factors and I
was really amazed when it was
recognizing and sit there so they
recognizing this plan and they think
this is infected so they are recognizes
the same volatize
we having citrus in the same voltage is
triggered by one effector in the coat
element am Jana
so this another
dogs and all dogs recognize these
buckets and these are a bucket with 16
plants so the dog very quickly
recognized these effectors
so we also line up these plants so every
plant was expressing one effectors and
at the end they recognized for effectors
and so so this dog are recognizing
Sheila's infected citrus at early stage
was ineffective marker these are
indirect recognition they use apologized
so our idea is now to develop an
antibody protein detection kit against
this effector molecule there are areas
pressed and they are detected by the
dogs so hopefully we can get we can be
using the groves and and they can detect
early they sink the bacillus in in
citrus leaves now the second task was a
mechanic inoculation and there is no
mechanical collation for Sheila's so far
so we develop a new way to inoculate
Sheila's implant and again Sheila's is
no culturable yet so he's a select
Sheila's infected got four for the
bacteria in any we use this system is a
3d printer device that can be attached
to the plan and communicated with the
vascular tissue so I stride this really
at the gut I struck the bacteria from
the gut and then I add the bacteria in
this system and then I will I wait 24
hours and then I his cookies yard to the
deck bacteria in the plant and in 24
hours I was able to detect Cilla's in
all the tissue and two months later also
I could detect Phyllis bacteria into the
leaf so this is a systemic infection and
to show you how it works
I now using a fluorescent problem so
again I'm using this fluorescent probe
this molecule in the device
I wait 24 hours and then I slice they
stem in the roots and then I look under
fluorescent microscope and you want to
see that right okay
these are the results so these are the
different section you can see the
fluorescent probe is a evenly
distributed in the vascular tissue
bought the stem but also in the roots
and so this system can deliver bacteria
but can also deliver molecules so why we
stopped there so we can use to screen
molecule against pathogens we can also
screen molecule against inset now we can
also use this device to deliver doubles
RNA to regulate us genes or we can
deliver doubles Renee for plant feeding
and then this this system will deliver
the molecule where they insert is
feeding so there was the second task and
this is a my last project and in this
project study interaction between fungus
and insect and to do that I'm using an
end to pathogenic fungi and we are going
to use this system to to measure citrus
to manage seed therefore in a cities
they seal it they transmit the bacteria
because right now the main control for
HIV is to control the vector so we want
to reduce the number of the vector and
to do that they use a chemical
insecticides but this is no sustainable
strategy first we have an environmental
pollution we read that there is a
reduction or three traffic interaction
and inks that can chemical is a
resistant to insects and we may have
some pesticide residue in a food and
obviously we need constant application
to maintain the
evenness so we are trying now these a
fungus is Aria femoral Xia and these are
the results after six days post
inoculation and the way we do is a
spraying the sport to the psyllids and
then we look the percent of mortality
over six days and you can see after six
day we have already almost 100% of
mortality but already after three days
you can see these symptoms on a psyllids
and in four days we have a the fungus
breaking through the skeleton and a six
day later the fungus is is ready to
spread again in fact recently or
vertically so these are intimate
photogenic fungal are well known but the
mechanism underlying the molecular
pathogenesis of enter multiple genic
fungi are rather limited
understood especially the effector
machinery has not been established in
the interaction between famosa and exit
so here again we are trying to identify
potential effector candidates and we
start with the coding protein counts and
we apply our filters and then we end up
with hundred seventy candidate effectors
and we are also combining this effector
with RNA sequences analysis and gene
expression and we found that many genes
many candidate effector higher early
area highly expressed during the first
hours also after 24 hours and after 72
hours and then a they goes down and this
is a very beginning of this project but
we also want to later to do some protein
in functional analysis and we can try to
express this protein plans or use
artificial diet and check inside the
quality and performance see what what
molecule are can interfere with a
withering set
and this was a my last slide so final
remarks
so most pathogens are defeated following
detection of conserved pathogen
molecules and pathogens deliver
molecules called effector inside their
austrian Abel infestation and effector
molecules our key component for all part
of systems and effector molecules can be
used as a guide to improve resistance in
plants and so would I to thank these
people that really helped me to build my
strength my career and help me to to
build my research program so thank you
[Applause]
the microphone isn't working out I'm
just curious in terms of the work and
research you've been doing if the
results of this is going to be of this
work is going to be more applicable in
terms of detecting the pathogen in the
in the citrus tree or is it going to be
more used in terms of actual control
procedures the problem yes well both we
want to use factors first we want to
identify the effective function what
they do we don't know yet the function
of these effectors oh they target so
when we know the target we may know the
function we know what the importance of
this molecule in the interaction it is
photosystem and then we can use these as
a tool to improve the sitter's resistant
we can but now we can for example we can
use if we can for resistant genes to
improve it
or the other way is to find the target
of these effectors maybe are susceptible
molecule so when we did really identify
the function we may find a way to do to
improve the resistance anyone else all
right so I have a dog question so the
dogs are detecting the volatile made by
the plant right and you're gonna be
working on making antibodies to the
effector right are you also working on
collecting headspace and seeing
identifying what these fossils could be
no these are scientific we will do it we
are this is a really recent so the idea
is actually to see what volatize are
expressed triggering and nicotine
tamiana with effector an effector and
also in situ is affected when affected
and see if there is an overlapping so we
will also look for a volatiles
hi I was really intrigued by the 3d
printed device that you attach and I was
curious if you know if the seal s is
actually alive so we think is alive
because two months later I can detect
gene expression so we are looking at DNA
and RNA and we look at the expression of
the effectors 28 effectors and they are
upregulated so it looks like the
bacteria is alive my question actually
follows straight on from that it's a
question about your seal as effectors
expressed in the plant is the population
size if you then infect the plant with
sealers it's the population size of the
sealers increased or decreased and does
it affect the transmissibility back to
the insect so it's asking about the
effect of proteins not from this
perspective of the immediate function
but in terms of the effect on the seal
ass and whether the seal as benefits
from the secretion of those proteins
so you have plants that are expressing
see less affect approach wise if have
you done the experiments to then infect
those PLAs would seal us and see if they
have a selection or we do not but we
were using nicotine remain tamiana and
it's difficult to infect incremental
Jana but right now we are expressed we
are generating transgenic citrus
expressing this factor so that case we
can try to inoculate seal us in this
transgenic plant see if increase or
decrease there the growth of the
bacteria so my question my question
follows on from the dog question if you
are if you make either a diagnostic or
some kind of treatment that's targeted
essentially at one of the effectors why
don't don't you expect to see less -
just drop that effector is there any
reason to think that it's essential for
infection we we think why we think is
important sorry other words why should
the dumb the effector if the effector is
what you're using - so recognize plants
that then need to be called say that's a
strong selective pressure against the
pathogen and there would be a strong
selective advantage for a pathogen that
dropped out effectors that you could no
longer detect and right but we are using
a cocktail of antibodies so it needs to
drop many effectors so in the case I
don't know if you can maybe did not
survive anymore if you keep the job all
the all the factors that's essentially
the question is how much do you know
about the essentialness for infection of
these effectors we don't know yet the
function we don't know the function we
know that the sum of the is factor our
earliest press six hour later we can
detect these effectors 24 hours later we
have a different waves of effectors a
week later we have a different waves of
effectors
but we still don't know the function day
we can put aside it the early effector
are important for modify modulated
finally phase responses then later
effector a probably important for
spreading the bacteria so the psyllid
the Silla is delivering see last little
flower right right is it possible that
your device is introducing see mass in
the desire limb as we're honest and it's
possible yeah we think is actually
possible because we see on the top of
the plant on the bottom of the roots so
the only way to go up is actually the
asylum in taking up taking the the
bacteria and moving up and possibly the
bacteria can move from the asylum to the
phloem because the day later we can see
the bacteria in the leaves there I study
the show that this bacteria sometimes
you can find index island and they
remove the floor him and the bacteria
can still move from one part of the plan
to another plant at the time so it's
possible but it is getting in it was
flown with your device that may be so I
am also but but your day I think a start
with exciting and then it moves back to
the phloem but we don't know yet because
we don't have a picture
you need to make picture of in section
and see where actually is present the
bacteria is there any evidence that some
of these effectors these plant effectors
are also expressed in the insect and
then injected through the saliva not
really made by the bacteria inside the
plant so that first way that you get six
hours I assume that you're delivering by
insects no these are grafting
inoculation we use a graft inoculation
or acp inoculation I mean that because
there is evident reversal is seamless
actually replicating when inside the
insect right and idea is also that
the ink said while sponsor in the cell
is actually injecting and potentially
effective from the bacteria so there is
already yeah
but the effectors are produced by
bacteria yeah there any other questions
are there any questions in Geneva okay
so please join me in thanking Marco once
again this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at cornell
edu